la vaccination piétine au brésil parce
que le gouvernement a tardé à commander
des vaccins ou a refusé à six reprises
les offres de files depuis août 2005 et
puis la chine a ralenti l'envoi de
principe actif du vaccin corona vague
fabriqués à san paolo
faute de vaccins le brésil est
probablement le seul pays au monde où
une bonne partie de la population compte
encore sur les propriétés préventives et
curatives de la chloroquine contre lacko
vide comme l'affirment
une fois de plus chez air ball sonar ou
autres fameuse plaque oif
c'est une canaille celui qui est contre
ce traitement contre la coved des
canailles qui n'ont pas d'autres options
je n'ai pas peur de dire à 10 millions
de gens que je les prie le premier visé
a été ce chercheur en médecine tropicale
de manaus en amazonie hauteur de la
toute première recherche sur
l'efficacité de la chloroquine contre
lacko vide en avril 2005 on a fait la
conclusion qu' il n'était pas efficace
et dangereuse voire mortelle à fortes
doses contre lacko vide
l'étude a porté sur plus de 400 patients
de l'hôpital de manaus où le traitement
est couramment utilisé contre la malaria
on a décidé de faire la communication
publiquement que la chloroquine ne
marchait pas orco vie 19 et ça a
commencé avec les problèmes politiques
mais bien au losc allant du tour un des
fils du président eduardo ball sonar
hausse en est immédiatement mêler les
fils du président a tweeté que on a fait
en étude pour à ces signes et les
patients seulement pour démontrer que
les clubs qui n'était pas efficace
le cauchemar aura duré près de trois
mois le médecin et son groupe de
chercheurs étaient accusés d'être des
agents de la gauche brésilienne ne sont
heureusement assez
spécialement pas le pas le les média
social
j'étais avec les agents de sécurité par
deux ou trois semaines à cause de la
famille ne savait pas qu est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui aura passé c'était très
difficile pour nous pour tous les
groupes avec la commission d' enquête du
sénat sur la gestion de la pandémie
la cpi les problèmes recommencent le mot
chloroquine a été utilisée 340 fois en
une semaine alors que les parlementaires
passe au grill les quatre ministres de
la santé qui se sont succédé le ton
monte au sénat un autre fils du
président le sénateur flavio boltro
traite le président de la commission de
vagabond ensuite reprise par son père le
président ball sonar ou est sur la
sellette
il sent le besoin de rehausser son image
avec la sphère de la chloroquine le
cafouillage dans l'acquisition des
vaccins et la gestion désastreuse de la
pandémie qui a fait plus de 430 mille
morts la popularité de jaillir bolson
araud a souffert mais pas tant que ça il
encore derrière lui un bon bloc solide
de 40% de brésiliens jean michel
leprince sera du canada à belley